[Musique]
moman cf en fête est née d'un constat
celui de l'universalité des violences
faites aux femmes et aux enfants et en
absence de dinde une réponse adéquate on
a créé en 2014
un lieu qui réunit en un même lieu donc
des juristes des avocats des médecins
donc on réunit en fait à santé et la
justice pour traiter des situations de
violence quelle que soit la forme de
violence des femmes et des enfants
absolument en sont à cette ambition là
elle correspond à une réalité de terrain
c'est en fait répondre beaucoup plus aux
besoins locaux sur le territoire en
dupliquant en fait une expertise qui
marche bien aujourd'hui les femmes
viennent de 51 départements
je pense qu'il faut maintenant réfléchir
à aller plus vers elle sait aussi nous
permettre de transmettre des savoirs
acquis par notre équipe d'experts etc en
fait modéliser un centre qui prend en
charge dans un bain mieux donc les
femmes et les enfants et que dans cette
prise en charge il est absolument
indispensable que l'enfant puisse aussi
avoir son espace de parole et donc il a
été créé depuis 2010 est donc il ya des
enfants qui aujourd'hui sont intégrés
dans notre réseau
alors ce concours effectivement il est
porté par la fabrique aviva et ses
partenaires qui propose en fait
d'appuyer des projets avec un impact
social important
l'enjeu est important puisque nous
cherchons des ressources financières
privées au delà des soutiens publics que
nous recevons aujourd'hui nous avons
besoin effectivement de ce type de
soutien
alors là l'enjeu c'est une somme de 60
mille euros points qui pourraient
effectivement être est reversé plus cent
mille euros si nous devions être les
premiers de ce qu'on va dire de ce panel
de porteurs de projets sociaux